mic runner Pro Football Focus lead draft
analyst and did a great job in summing
up the draft you had great opinions
there and Mike joins us now Mike good
morning let me start with the Jordan
love trade explain it tell me the good
of the Packers taking Jordan love well
the good is with the rest of their draft
has got ended up being their best pick
actually so the good is that he has the
tools like the patch of mahomes
comparison that everyone wants to make
it's not fair to him he doesn't
necessarily have that level of ability
or even that level of performance at
college but he has that natural arm
talent you saw it on a safe at Utah
State we tracked these things called
big-time throws here at PFF which are
special downfield throws with accuracy
you were still top five in the nation
last year in that category
despite play was not a lot of talent
around him at Utah State so that's what
you fall in love with with him the pick
though I can't get on board in the
national media no one seems to be able
to get on worth it just because of Aaron
Rodgers four years left on his contract
Jordan love up and down over the course
of his career almost made a Pyxis
touchdowns last year you better be right
about this evaluation if you're Brian
Goodykoontz or else you just drafted a
guy who didn't even play at a big school
who's not wasn't even good last year to
usurp Aaron Rodgers do you like Jordan
love better than Justin Herbert I'll say
I'd rather come away from the first
round with Jordan love than Justin
Herbert because I think he can get to
that level like I think his ceiling
could be a top 10 quarterback in the NFL
Justin Herbert for as much as you know
the big arm that evaluators fall in love
with and looks the part looks great in
shorts he didn't have that level of you
know downfield accuracy or level of
accuracy just in general
now we operated the offense there at
Oregon State a little bit better he's a
little bit more capable right at the
moment but he's the same guy we saw as a
sophomore Edward at Oregon his grade
actually peaked sophomore year the
things you wanted to see improve more
throws with touch more you know improve
accuracy more command to the offense you
didn't see over the course of his career
so usually guys are four-year stars and
college you like it but the fact they
didn't get any better is almost a
negative Inara
what should the Chargers have done they
should have moved up I mean quite
frankly I thought going in that that was
their plan they were gonna move up to
get to a tongue of my lower you
because they need people to fill that
stadium their laughingstock to be on FL
not filling out an MLS stadium they need
to sell tickets you know sell season
tickets there to was a guy that moves
the needle personality-wise you know
with what he's done and the stats he had
at Alabama I think he's a much much
better quarterback prospect I can't see
how you could evaluate both them and not
kind of that conclusion so I don't know
what it would have taken for them to
move up I don't think it would have
taken that much because you know anyone
would have moved up with would have
gotten the same guy so crazy to me that
they didn't in stuck and got Herbert
when you look at your draft strategy
when you apply these grades how do you
come up with your formula that you're
gonna give somebody an A or an A+ or
give somebody a c-minus so that part is
not as scientific as some of the that
was more a little subjective okay we do
it is based on whether that we value
them on our draft board and more so what
we factor into our draft board that a
lot of people might not is the
positional value that you're getting
with these picks if you're drafting or
running back in the second round you're
just not going to recruit your value the
way you could with say a cornerback with
a pass rusher or something in at that
point in the draft so that's one thing
we factor in heavily here at pro
football but you have the Chiefs taking
a running back at the end of the first
round and it's not who they take it's
when they take him because then the
Lions take Swift in the second round so
that which one's smarter explain your
philosophy on that so running backs that
the biggest thing is I mean the Chiefs
off themselves
you've got a guy off the street who was
damn near Super Bowl MVP because what
matters at the running back position in
terms of production is not necessarily
skill like the the evaluation of the
skill level is one of the least
important things in terms of how many
yards per carry they get in and how
productive your rushing offense is it's
much more plays calling it's much more
the quality of your offensive line that
matters to those things to the success
were not success of your running game
the running backs a small cog in that
part in that puzzle and the fact that
matters are just a lot of guys who are
dynamic running threats at the position
there's a lot of running backs who are
talented and so that's why you see a guy
like Phillip Lindsey goes you DFA and
have a higher yards per carry with the
first two you
of his career then said Clym barkley who
went number two overall that's just it's
a fact of life in the NFL and so we
don't want to be taking the ball on a
patch of mahomes hands we think he's
that good we think that passing offense
is that dynamic that if you draft a guy
in the first round and Clyde Edwards
Hilaire you almost have to give him
carries to justify that pick and that's
taking the ball iPad from the homes
hands all right well then using that
philosophy or those opinions
if I go back obviously Leonard fournette
then is a bad draft pick for
Jacksonville no matter what he did say
Quan Barkley is a bad draft pick for the
Giants considering where they took him I
believe so and it's the opportunity cost
what you gave up with a number two
overall pick you could have drafted guys
and I'm trying to think back to that
draft who was all on the board you could
have actually obviously a quarterback
well quit in Ocean you could have
ejected a guard and Quinton Nelson and
you look at the Colts offensive in the
rushing game over the past few years has
been better than the Giants rushing game
over the past two years because that
offensive line is what matters to the
run game and they off and also when you
invest in that offensive line and you
draft those guys up front it also has an
added effect to the passing game because
the best-run blockers are also usually
the best pass protectors so that's where
I'm gonna invest if I do want to improve
my running game there were a couple of
teams that I liked with what they did
and then I sort of changed my opinion
after I read what Pro Football Focus was
talking about you know did the Ravens
have a good draft felt like the Cowboys
had a good draft I like what the Lions
did I'm still got a question mark with
the dolphins because I got a question
with tua and even Austin Jackson who
they took later in the first round as a
project so grade my grade I will say the
Dolphins they win just because to Otunga
by llola at number five is a slam dunk
and any other year he doesn't have the
hip whatever he goes number one overall
Jill burger doesn't exist we're talking
about him as the number one overall pick
right now so that getting him at fifth
when usually a guy like that goes either
first or second in every single draft is
a massive win for them not having trade
up the Austin Jackson pick first round
is where it is not where you take
projects on the offensive tackle
position because athletic tools that
offensive tackle don't necessarily
translate we look at your combine data
the combine data at the often stacked
position is not near
as predictive to future success as it is
for a lot of other positions so you can
chase guys who have the athleticism that
doesn't mean they're gonna be good
pros in Austin Jackson his tape at USC
was not great I mean he got beaten a lot
especially look at the bull game against
Iowa and a JEP Anessa three sacks he
allowed that game so not great there so
I go back and forth still a good draft
getting your franchise quarterback
though the Ravens is the one where yes
love the linebacker pick and some of the
ones later on but they had Gus Edwards
averaging five and a half yards per
carry you dfa going back to that running
back conversation didn't necessarily
need to get a JK Dobbins there I'm not
sure what he brings to the table that
they didn't necessarily already have no
Cowboys a little lower I like what the
Cowboys did I think it was a smart you
know Jerry usually has that Jerry the
owner has the temptation to do something
crazy you know felt like Jerry the GM
and Jerry the owner were on the same
page I love the Cowboys draft one of the
four a-pluses we gave out with Dallas's
and the CD land pick while it might may
seem decadent to get that third receiver
in there Mike McCarthy uses three wide
receivers that was like his mo in Green
Bay was he never took those three
receivers off the field it was like 90
plus percent of their snaps so that
means TV land to start it means from day
one and he was going to be playing for
them and we had him as the sixth overall
player in this draft class we love that
picking them to get Trayvon Diggs in the
second round the Alabama cornerback
second longest wingspan of any
cornerback in this draft class he only
allowed 160 yards all season long
outside of that LSU game that everyone
remembers from getting torched but the
rest of year he dominated people thought
they might have taken him in the first
round took him all the way in a second
so just slam dunk those first and second
round picks at valuable positions and
our eyes Cowboys one of the best draft
okay so Cowboys get an A+ did you give
the Dolphins an A+
I did not think I can't remember off top
of my head what in Dolphins let's go to
Dave pushes other a pluses were the
Cleveland Browns they got three guys
their first three picks were top 75
their top 25 players on our draft board
and Jordan Elliott Grant Delpit and
Jedrek wills there in the first round
also the Arizona Cardinals who got
Isaiah Simmons in the first Josh Jones
and the third which in my opinion was
the steal of the draft the Houston
offensive tackle yeah you know the 14th
player on our draft board they
offensive line help thought they'd go
there in the first job to get that guy
in the third was crazy and you got a
factor in the DeAndre Hopkins trade like
a second-round pick to flip that into
DeAndre Hopkins massive win for them and
then the last a plus for us was the gosh
I had blanking your Denver Broncos gosh
yeah
so Jerry Judi KJ hammer they had a theme
of this draft and that was to get you
lock the weapons he needs the speed he
needs and also Alberto at tight end who
ran a 449 they're gonna they're gonna go
toe to toe with the Kenton State Chiefs
in terms of speed and out in the AFC
West and get through like every chance
he needs to succeed they're the worst
grade that you handed out was the Green
Bay Packers and like I said for Jordan
love to be their best selection was
crazy to me I thought I told you that
after the first day you would have said
I was dead wrong but then they draft a
running back a backup running back in
the second round and a fullback in the
third round they drafted I feel with
1989 it was good stuff Mike I really
enjoyed reading it and we appreciate you
coming on for sure dad thanks for adding
out much Mike Renner
yeah Pro Football Focus lead draft
analyst